achtung teile dieser sendung könnten sie
verärgern oder verstören
mit dieser warnung gekommen zu einer
sternstunde in der summe gender
sternchen und umstrittene
nobelpreisträger geht genauso wie um
literatur klassiker unter rassismus
verdacht oder popstars deren songs nicht
mehr gespielt werden sollten
die frage nach der moral sie nimmt in
der beurteilung von kunst kultur und
politik ja unserer wortwahl selbst immer
größeren raum ein
gut so und wenn ja für wen erörtern will
ich diese frage mit der österreichischen
philosophen listen und dem deutsch
amerikanischen literaturwissenschaftler
hans ulrich gumbrecht herzlich
willkommen hirnich sagte es und habe
eine beispiel einige beispiele auch
schon genannt würden sie denn sagen dass
mehr als in den letzten jahrzehnten die
beurteilung von moralischen kriterien
für personen künstler in den raum
getreten ist dass wir da einen trend
erleben also ja ich würde der
beobachtung zustimmen
zumindest was jetzt meinen eigenen
erfahrungshorizont angeht hat sich
einiges getan vor allem mit dem
aufkommen
von internet sozialen medien und ja das
betrifft auch den kunstbereich aber wir
erleben dass auch im
wissenschaftsbereich und dem politischen
bereich auf jeden fall
sie sind ja gegen hat die agnostiker
herum rechte noch mithalten älteren
epochen sehr gut vertraut
jetzt könnte man sagen die moralische
sichtweise ist zunächst eine abnahme die
vorschrift fortschritt sozialen
fortschritt anzeigt würden sie denn
sagen dass das auch ein fortschritt in
unserer kultur ist wenn es denn so wäre
es könnte ja sein also ich halte in
diesem speziellen fall dass was passiert
nicht unbedingt für einen fortschritt
ich denke also was wäre meine antwort
wenn es wenn kein fortschritt ist es ein
symptom einer universalen verunsicherung
und um das zu belegen als der älteste
und uns dreien dass sich etwas verändert
hat also mein vater war chirurg und aus
franken und hat mit dem dortigen akzent
immer von der ärztlichen ethik geredet
also ärztliche ethik und ich kann mich
erinnern als ich zehn bis 20 jahre alt
war wenn er das ab und an gesagt habe
war mir das furchtbar peinlich weil
sonst niemand das wort ethik verwendet
hat ja moral sowieso nicht also das war
in den 60er jahren an dem ich mich jetzt
erinnere in den späten 50er jahren war
einfach der gebrauch des wortes und auch
der gebrauch solcher fragen und solche
diskussionen da galt vieles als
selbstverständlich das ist nicht
unbedingt positiv aber das nur noch
wenig als selbstverständlich gelten kann
ist glaube ich deswegen sage ich
verunsicherung ist der grund warum
dieses wort so oft gebraucht wird und
warum die diskussion so virulent und
lebhafter sind sie sagten das ja das hat
auch mediale gründe es gibt neue formen
die eigene meinung die eigenen bedenken
zu verbalisieren öffentlich zu machen
und wir haben jetzt ein ganz aktuelles
beispiel dieser moralisierung tendenz im
fall peter handke den nobelpreisträger
der aufgrund seiner äußerungen zum rolle
serbien im balkankrieg ein wenig unter
moralischen druck geraten ist möchte ich
mal sagen und es gibt ja eine ganze
kampagne wir sehen hier ein kleines bild
in bezug auf diese verleihung wie würden
sie das einschätzen teil
teil dieser situation ja auf jeden fall
teil dieser situation aber peter handke
ist nicht der einzige fall also wir
haben die diskussionen auch gehabt auch
in österreich zum todestag zum
geburtstag von michael jackson darf man
ihn überhaupt noch hören
jetzt ist die frage darf man biete hand
genug lesen ich glaube das dilemma dass
da rauskommt ist dass wir nie eine
wirklich ein wirkliches bekenntnis dafür
hatten dass wir vielleicht kunstwerk und
schöpfer schöpferin trennen müssen
wobei ich finde da kommt eine extreme
doppelmoral auch zum ausdruck denn wir
haben in der kunst in der
geisteswissenschaft diese bedenken aber
nicht in der naturwissenschaft
beispielsweise ja also wir haben kein
problem wenn die zilien oder sonstige
medikamente zu nehmen egal ob der
mediziner der wissenschaftler die
wissenschaftlerin
rassistische sexistische war oder wie
auch immer aber wir haben ein großes
problem wenn es um kunstwerke geht oder
wenn es um thesen aus der
geisteswissenschaft geht also da würde
ich sagen da kommt eine sehr sehr starke
doppelmoral zu vorschein interessante
these vor allem für an
kulturwissenschaftler wie sie ja das ist
interessant weil es hat respekt ii wie
auch bei und mit recht
naturwissenschaftlern bedenken gegeben
aber die frage also ob eine diskussion
ähnlich wie die hand des mission bei
einem nobelpreis in
wirtschaftswissenschaften physik oder
chemie denkbar ist muss man mit nein
beantworten das ist das spiel keine
rolle ja also anderer fall übrigens also
eben wieder auch kunst und den ich also
der in seinen konsequenzen ungeheuer
markant ist woody allen
also es ist in dem land in dem ich lebe
und dessen bürger ich bin in den usa
eigentlich nicht mehr möglich auch wenn
man sich bemüht den letzten woody allen
film zu sehen ja das kann sich kein kino
leisten auch keinen spezialisten kino
keine universität kann sich's leisten
also dass die downloadmöglichkeit
bereitzustellen
das ist mit einer konsequenz in dem fall
also weiter gegangen wobei in dem fall
keine buch das ist eine offene
rechtslage sozusagen also die die
vorwürfe die ihm gemacht wurden wurden
sozusagen die juristisch bewiesen als es
ist eine offene diskussion und trotzdem
ist wohl die ärmel auch historisch
möglich doch die alten filme nicht mehr
sozusagen vom von von der oberfläche des
planeten verschwunden was sehr
interessant ist an diesen fällen dass es
gibt eine frauen der ächtung der offenen
sozialen ächtung die stark polarisieren
wird und wer immer in dieses kraftfeld
gerät dazu dann gar nicht mehr über das
werk selbst geredet sondern man wird
teil eines lagerwahlkampfes der sich
vollständig verselbständigt hat man das
gefühl ich glaube und das passt ja auch
zum zum titel von von ihrem neuen buch
ja also ich glaube wir uns nicht nur mit
einer brüchigen gegenwart zu tun sondern
tatsächlich auch es zeigt uns die
brüchige moral mit der wir umgehen also
diese ohnmacht auch wo gibt es diese
moralische autorität also religion tiere
dieser alten konservativen player gibt
es so nicht mehr zumindest wären sie
nicht zu ernst genommen
jetzt kommt mir vor diese diese hoffnung
dass auf die kunst auf die künstler zu
projizieren also die hätten diese
moralische autorität ihr werk
partizipation im werk würde quasi das
gute fördern ja all diese klischees
glaube sprechen jetzt einfach sehr stark
auf und ich finde es auch interessant
wenn man es nochmal weiter denkt was
passiert mit den werken von autoren
autorinnen die schon tot sind
ja also wie weit muss jemand nachweisbar
moralisch integer sein damit ich sein
werk ihr werk noch lesen kann
ja also das ist ja auch diese illusion
von wir könnten die biografie durch
geschichtswissenschaft perfekt studieren
wir können den charakter zu legen und
erst wenn wir feststellen können das war
ganz sicher kein pathologischer
charakter dann dann war es dann kriegen
wir das prädikat werk ist lesen war
wieder auf also das wird sich so auf
jeden fall nicht ausgehen können weil
wir auch diese vollständigkeit nicht
mehr bekommen können aber ich würde auch
nicht als wünschenswert denken also ich
denke wie gesagt diese doppelmoral
aufzuzeigen
ich jetzt da auch für eine aufgabe von
videos oder software gesehen schon die
grenze von der moral zur doppelmoral die
ist eine sehr fließende und schwer zu
ziehen
aber es gibt noch ein anderes wort gegen
moral hat ja an sich niemand etwas gegen
das moralisieren schon das wirkt wie ein
strategischer ansatz her gumbrecht kann
man da eigentlich sagen das moralisieren
und die moral kann man die voneinander
trennen und wo würden sie diese grenze
ziehen leuten also subjektiv wäre ich
schon nervös und die gänsehaut setzte
ein wenig moral höre ja also ich meine
nicht beschreiben von außen dass man
sagt also es hat bestimmte moralische
informationen ist eine veränderung
moralischer werte gegeben
das schon aber wenn also in eine alltags
konversation sehr viel von moral geredet
wird welche nervös beim organisieren
weniger weil moralisierend imperativ ist
aber verwöhnt das wort moralisieren nie
positiv
niemand der gerne moralisiert würde
sagen ich moralisieren
ich denke also wenn wir jetzt von den
wörtern reden das ist vielleicht gar
nicht uninteressant das wort ethik ist
das neue wort also was überall verwendet
wird was mir eben als dem ältesten hier
auffällt nicht nur im deutschen ja ich
meine erste group bank sowie politiker
responsive politics korrekt ecologic sie
sind das sind die amerikanischen therme
die auch in unserem kulturkreis
einsparte naja von amerika aus also die
zb das korrekt nicht also korrekt wurde
mit mit sehr vielen adverbien verbunden
also ecologic die korrekt politisch
völlig inkorrekt usw usw
und diese inflation als symptom macht
mir ein unbehagen weil sie von den
meisten teilnehmern an der diskussion
erst mit dem anspruch verbunden ist sie
hätten eine überlegene kompetenz woran
sich zu entscheiden und zweitens mit der
erwartung dass es am ende eine
verbindliche lösung geben muss nicht und
meine erfahrung ist
ich würde sogar sagen meine
philosophische position ist die gibt es
in sehr vielen fällen nicht ja man kann
sich dann vielleicht einige man kann
konzessionen machen aber immer voraus zu
setzen
da gibt es die richtige lösung und die
muss dann auffällig werden ist
problematisch und ich meine dass der
nächste diskussions horizont ist dann
der staat also die die das ideal wäre
immer dass das sofort von dem
gesetzgeber sozusagen auch juristisch
verbindlich gemacht
wir sind kommen und schon wirklich der
sache sehr viel näher bei korrekt sagt
ja ist die sehnsucht nach einem standard
und seine matte rechnung korrekt oder
korrekt gelöst
also es gibt ein standard problem es
gibt eine institution problem wäre
eigentlich festhält was korrekt ist und
da kommt der ruf nach dem staat ein
glutkern der entzweiung in diesem spiel
um die moral ist ja die frage nach den
geschlechtern im weitesten sinne da
meint man das politisch korrekte
sprechen und viele andere fragen werden
wirklich popularisieren freiherrn sie
beschäftigen sich viel mit
feministischen fragen mit diesem diskurs
warum in zwei der gerade in hinsichtlich
der moralisierung so stark er ist es
immer einen im möchte mit ganz kurz zu
diesem diesen korrekte begriff
zurückkommen stimmig absolut zu ich
glaube auch dass dieser versuch korrekt
so sagen ja auch schon die ohnmacht
gegenüber einer fragestellung ausdruck
diebe nicht beantworten können
und im endeffekt würde ich mir ja auch
videos antworten
also da würde ich mir ja eigentlich auch
von der philosophie von von allen die in
diesen diesem feld auch arbeiten
wünschen dass ich das noch viel viel
kritischer sehen und und nicht in den
modus übergehen aber das würde ja auch
das ende überhaupt von nachfragen und
diskussion bedeuten also derjenige der
sagt ich weiß dass korrekt ist sagt er
nicht nur das sondern sagt auch was
richtig und was falsch ist
wir sind eigentlich dann auf dem selben
standard von playern die kritisiert
werden wie kirche religion und so weiter
also damit ist die diskussion beendet
ist sie natürlich in dem fall nicht ich
glaube das ist auch was polarisiert
nämlich dass man dann sagen so einfach
lässt sich die diskussion aber nicht
beenden
das sind fehler da werden wir keinen
konsens erzielen ich glaube keiner
dieser dieser fehler ist ja das thema
geschlechterfragen oder geschlechter und
verhältnis von geschlecht und einander
was ich gut finde oder wo ich vielleicht
etwas positives dieser ganzen diskussion
auch um um schreibweisen und und auch
sprach gerechtigkeit abgewinnen kann ist
der punkt tatsächlich das sichtbarkeit
von strukturen von machtstrukturen und
auch dass dadurch eine gewisse
provokation ist diese in frage zu
stellen
und ich kann mich an eine diskussion
erinnern wo ein älterer kollege von mir
rechts philosophieprofessor mal sagte er
jetzt in seiner position mit töchtern
und enkeln wer eigentlich dafür dass wir
uns jetzt darauf einigen dass wir nur
die ihnen weise bevorzugen also kein
großes e mail sondern er wird eigentlich
für ein kleines i plädieren ich war
vollkommen schockiert also wir sagen ich
verlosen die nach sofia was wir machen
also wenn ihre ski maskulin und genau
weil man denkt ja einfach mit also
denken wir jetzt die männer mit und ich
kann mich erinnern dass ich mich da wie
steht dass ich auch sehr schockiert war
von diesem vorschlag
da können sich an männer nicht mit kind
mal enthüllen ja was mich dazu bewogen
hat schon nochmal kritischer dieses
ganze feld zu reflektieren
jetzt nicht dass ich denke dass wir
durch kleine vereinzelte sprachliche
maßnahmen wird die sprache komplett
umgestalten können
ich bin auch nicht so naiv zu glauben
dass es reicht sprachlich erinnerungen
zu machen um wirklichkeit zu verändern
was ist aber macht und das finde ich gut
es regt diskussion an
und ja ich finde dass ethik als begriff
jetzt schon inflationär gebraucht wird
aber ich finde es tatsächlich schön dass
die diskussion über gender sternchen
binnen-i mittlerweile wirklich breit der
bevölkerungsschichten auch erreicht die
überhaupt nicht in den diskurs vorher
eingebunden waren also das würde ich
sagen ist das was ich mal positiv
abgewinnen kann
die explizit machen dessen was wir
stillschweigend annehmen und was
diskriminierend wirken kann
würden sie sagen dass es ein fortschritt
aspekt dieses sprach streits ja ich
glaube schon dass also ein letztes mal
mein altem ein hohes alter 71
in anspruch nehmen kann mich heute
fragen würde
hat es denn überhaupt irgendetwas
gegeben was man mit dem prädikat
fortschritt bezeichnen könnte in meiner
lebenszeit dann ist schon dass ich da
das da was in bewegung gekommen ist dass
sich das verändert hat dass es neue
sensibilitäten gibt ja ich würde fast
sagen obwohl mir der begriff auch
gänsehaut macht dass es neue normen gibt
neue werte und so weiter und wenn es
sehr positiv ihre interpretation ihre
these zu den verschreibungen der
sprachlichen gebräuche finde ich
interessant das provoziert das recht an
gerade wenn es ein lästig ist gerade
wenn es zu kompliziert ist gerade wenn
es am vorkommt wie ein fünffacher
eingesprungene axel dass man das jetzt
auch noch mal sagen muss aber es regt
zum denken an manchmal denke ich dass
die konsequenzen dessen der aus versehen
oder aus ungeschicklichkeit ein fehler
macht zu groß sind ja es wird also sehr
sehr schnell
ich denke nicht unter amerikanischen
bedingungen mehr als unter europäischen
bedingungen aber sicher unter
amerikanischen bildung das ist mein
alltag die rote karte gezogen
da werden dinge und intentionen
unterstellt die eigentlich nur
erworbener sprachgewohnheiten also sind
kann ein beispiel vielleicht nenne meine
initialen also hans ulrich gumbrecht lg
und das heißt auf englisch haag also
eine umarmung und ich habe in einer
e-mail mit also meinen dass bach öfter
mit meinen initialen und der bedeutung
des worts hat gespielt und das hat
tatsächlich also eine kollegin
für einer demonstration sondern die iss
samt sprossen also die personalkosten
oder frau gegangen ist hat keine
konsequenzen für mich gehabt aber wenn
ich pech gehabt hätte hätte das
konsequenzen haben können die ich glaube
also wenn mir einer sagt macht diese
wortspiele nicht weil manche leute haben
eine sensibilität dann lernt man das ja
also ich glaube sehr viele männer haben
in den letzten jahrzehnten in der
hinsicht viel gelernt weil ich zunächst
mal gesagt ich meine doch überhaupt
nichts bewiesen ist aber dass meine
absicht nicht entscheidend ist dafür wie
ein sprachgebrauch irritieren können das
ist glaube ich sehr wichtig und ich kann
mich noch erinnern als sich lange
dagegen argumentiert damit meine absicht
gut ist muss auch der sprachgebrauch
akzeptabel sein aber es ist nicht so als
es gibt sport gebräuchen die leute
irritieren das sind ja nicht nur
genderfragen sondern auch etwa ethnische
stereotype und so weiter und so weiter
und insofern ist sicher was in bewegung
gekommen und mir gefällt ihre these der
irritation durch die sozusagen
denkanstöße denkt impulse in den
altrhein gelassen obwohl ich da jetzt
auch noch das ja dazu sagen würde ist
dass zb der umgang mit mit alten texten
er da auch noch mal sehr interessant ist
weil ich finde auch ich bin zum beispiel
an eine verfechterin der position dass
es wichtig ist problematische begriffe
an zu zeichnen
ich bin nicht eine verfechterin sie
unbedingt zu ersetzen und zwar aus dem
grund auch weil sie auch nicht nur einen
denken sondern auch eine situation und
einen zugang zu einem werk zu einer idee
abbilden ja also ich finde zum beispiel
da einen eingriff zu machen und zu sagen
gut wir ersetzen jetzt die fünf begriffe
die jetzt nicht mehr politisch
akzeptabel sind oder nicht politisch
korrekt sind durch euphemismen halte ich
zum beispiel sehr dringlichen sich an
also das würde ich zum beispiel ableger
ich nehme ein aktuelles beispiel aus dem
kinderbuch bei pippi langstrumpf gibt es
den [ __ ] könig ausdruck taka-tuka-land
in der originalversion der soll jetzt
zum südsee könig werden und das ist wohl
auch verändert worden in den neuen
ausgabe jetzt kann man sagen kein kind
geht etwas verloren dabei
wenn diese doch tendenziell rassistische
wortwahl ersetzt wird aber verstehe ich
sie richtig da werden so art retro
aktive standards eingeführt und in
gewisser weise auch die geschichte als
geschichte verfälscht durch diese
änderungen also ich glaube es ist
tatsächlich zumutbar dass sich kinder
und auch die eltern und erwachsenen die
sich mit dem kind beschäftigen
das kind darauf hinweisen können welchen
bedeutungswandel ein wort durchmachen
kann das wenig wesentlich und das muss
unbedingt sein also ich finde es nicht
gut weg herauszugeben mit wörtern die
wir es nicht mehr akzeptabel finden die
nicht mit den standards entsprechen
ich finde es aber mit einem einen guten
hinweis versehen und in absprache mit
dem erwachsenen überhaupt
unproblematisch ich sind ich finde das
ist zumutbar und ich finde es auch
wichtig wie das verständnis von kindern
und jugendlichen wie auch welt
funktioniert es auch das sind begriffe
sich entwickeln das sich gesellschaft
entwickelt also dazu sagen ich möchte
das nicht zumuten weil es könnte
schmerzvolle gefühle hervorrufen könnte
es auch arbeits könnte auch eine
anregung sein aus diesem schmerz zu
sehen dass sich entwicklungen ergeben
das war natürlich da also also erstens
wir müssen irgendwann wurde nicht
erstens kann man ja sagen dass man
eigentlich das verhältnis zur geschichte
aufgibt und unterminiert wenn man
beständig alle irritationen auf höchst
nicht also geschichte ist anders sein
also anders hat aber das große know und
wenn ich beständig anpassen wenn nicht
beständig problematische begriffe
rausnehmen
dann habe ich eigentlich keiner ist das
verhältnis zur geschichte in eine
intellektuelle teuren weise also
verflacht was die sensibilitäten angeht
also ich habe ja vorhin schon mit
fliegenden fahnen bei gestimmt und
möchte auch die position beibehalten
aber es gibt natürlich eine dimension
die denke ich psychologisch
philosophisch politisch relevant ist ob
das absolute vermeiden des schmerzes
existenziell gesehen
die norm sein sollte
ist eine frage nicht nur weil man sich
an schmerz gewonnen muss und da muss man
irgendwie trainieren sondern vielleicht
auch weil schmerz als existenzielle
dimension versucht mal paradoxon zu
formulieren eine ist die ich nicht
missen möchte
also ein mehr von mir sehr geschätzte
französischen philosoph der heute nicht
mehr sehen mode ist jean françois
lyotard hatte man am artikel der sehr
lesenswert ist für unsere zuschauer ob
man ohne körper denken kann ist aus dem
französischen übersetzt der titel eine
asymmetrie zwischen den geschlechtern
entwickelt und hat gesagt er traut den
frauen existenziell mehr zu
bald geschlechter pragmatisch gesehen
frauen eine größere vertrautheit mit
schmerz haben einmal bei ihnen
historisch mehr zugemutet worden ist
aber auch weil sowas für viele frauen
zutrifft zum beispiel der moment der
geburt der geburt schmerz existenziell
nicht gemischt werden sollte also das
beispiel jetzt gut ist es noch eine
andere frage aber dieses aushebeln und
eliminieren der dimension schmerz aus
dem alltäglichen leben und ich meine
jetzt sowohl physischen schmerz im
konkreten sinn also psychologischen das
könnte konsequenzen haben die wir heute
noch nicht absehen wie problematisch das
ist ganz interessante idee dass
verletzungen auch reifen lassen
weiterbringen ein moment der
persönlichen entwicklung sein kann nie
gesagt was mich nicht umbringt macht
dich stärker das ist eine variation
dieses gedankens sie haben es beide
festgehalten
das fand ich sehr wichtig dass es einen
großen fortschritt gab einen wandelnden
horizont der auch eine emanzipatorische
und war
wir hatten vor wenigen wochen die us
historikerin hier und die hat ihre
eigene gedanken zur dynamik von moral
und geschichtlichen fortschritt da
schauen wir uns mal ganz kurz an
sie entwickeln und perfektionieren was
ich den weiblichen moralischen kreuzzug
nenne so kämpfen sie für die abschaffung
der sklaverei und dafür dass weniger
alkohol getrunken wird
sie kämpfen für den frieden sie werden
populistin die lebens rechts bewegung
ist ein kreuzzug
wie auch die metro bewegung denn frauen
sind politisch immer noch nicht
gleichberechtigt
die these von chile vor lautet wenn man
keine politische macht hat nimmt man die
moral um sich gehör zu verschaffen
die moral ist in gewisser weise das
machtmittel der wehrlosen vielleicht was
nietzsche die sklaven moral nennen würde
das heißt es ist ein instrumentaler
einsatz der vor allem von den ideen
gewählt wird die sich kein gehör
verschaffen können nicht nur sondern
auch wobei ich da noch mal den gedanken
von politik als teil der ethik noch mal
viel viel stärker einbringen würde also
auch diese diese trennung die eine
zeitlang irgendwie propagiert worden ist
ja also dann politiker nicht moralisch
beurteilen zu wollen sondern dass die
entscheidungen die sie treffen jetzt
rein theologische orientiert sind
wirtschaftlichen interessen entsprechen
müssen um so weiter ja eigentlich dazu
geführt hat dass nicht nur sie als
moralische autorität irgendwie in na ja
obsolet geworden sind jetzt kann ich als
österreicherinnen nach ibiza affäre
erzählt er nur sagen so einfach ist es
nicht
also politiker politikerinnen
repräsentieren etwas ja und auch die
parteien die jetzt mehr oder weniger
stimmen haben gehen ja auch auf
spezielle gruppen ein
also einfach nur zu sagen die
ohnmächtigen bedienen sich nur der moral
das würde ich nicht sagen ganz im
gegenteil wir lebens auch in österreich
so stark dass auch selber gekonnt über
die gesichter moral bedienen also wenn
es um leistungsbereitschaft geht um die
gegenüberstellung von leistungs bringen
und den leistungsverweigerung
und ja da ist dann halt auch nur ein
ganz kurzer weg wer zu den
leistungsverweigerung gehört also wie
definiere ich jetzt leistung leistung im
sinne von vollzeitjob leistung im sinne
von von werken die ich schaffe und dann
ist die frage auch eine
geschlechterfrage wo ziel ist die frauen
dazu ja also wenn ich jetzt nach den
einnahmen nach dem gehalt spiegel de
können sie wahrscheinlich eher zum
leistungsverweigerung
alles zu den leistungsträgern also so
einfach überdies nicht sagen ja also ich
würde auch nicht sagen dass jetzt die
man sich jetzt nur eine eine
konservative strategie es ist auch eine
progressive strategie
ich bin beide lager können verwenden
also die moral ist nicht nur als sklaven
moral sondern auch als herrn x als sehr
gut spa also den fall als natürlich
gegeben und das ist richtig aber es ist
erstens aber das hat die frau auch nicht
gemeint ich denke nicht gemeint man kann
nicht sagen dass immer wenn eine solche
situation der machtlosigkeit besteht das
politische instrument ein instrument der
moralist nicht also wenn ich mich weil
sie meine these zu der heutigen
situation dauert ungefähr so was er
lautet so also ich möchte so beschreiben
die verwendeten kompakten begriff ich
sage ein universum der kontingenz das
heißt situation die früher
ausnahmesituationen situationen mit dem
mann konfrontiert ist wenn man mehrere
wahlmöglichkeiten hat haben überhand
genommen und die meisten situationen
unseres alltags sind solche situationen
ohne selbstständigkeit das ist erstens
ein großer gewinn an freiheit nicht
nichts ist selbstständig nicht nichts
kann man sozusagen selbstständig
einklagen
aber es ist zugleich eine überlasst von
komplexität und insofern denke ich und
das ist meine phobie gegen die inflation
des ethik begriffs dass die die für sich
in anspruch nehmen und behaupten dass in
jeder dieser fragen eine verbindliche
lösung existieren muss dass die das tun
was ein deutscher philosoph der
soziologe niklas luhmann in einem
schlechten sinne reduktion von
komplexität genannte verlängerung
verringerung von komplexität
man tut so als gäbe es eine lösung in
einer situation wo es die lösung nicht
gibt und man konnte hier sagen die die
interessante spezifität dieser gegenwart
unserer gegenwart ist dass auf der einen
seite individuell geht
ich denke ich ungeheure zugewinn an
freiheit existieren also als ich bei
meinen eigenen kindern ich habe vier
davon gesehen habe wie lange das am
teenager heute kostet eigentlich den
ganzen donnerstag das wochenende zu
planen was nicht selbstverständlich ist
gibt also kirchgang oder fußball am
samstagnachmittag leidenberger unter uns
sportfans also man muss sozusagen jedes
wochenende alles ganz neu planen und das
ist ein freiheitsgewinn das ist
positiver das bedeutet auf der anderen
seite dass die verbindlichkeiten oder
den selbstverständlichkeiten wenig sind
und das ist meine phobie mit dem
anspruch dass es lösungen geben muss
weil man damit dann auch beengend wird
weil man damit dann auch die eröffneten
freiheits räume wieder ein schritt und
ich verstehe sie richtig die moral ist
in gewisser weise diejenigen die diese
komplize die komplexität auf der
eindeutigkeit für uns reduzieren will
das ist ihr einsatz an diesem stück das
ist sie haben mich leider gottes da kann
man keine diskussion ganz genau richtig
verstanden aber vielleicht noch eine
provokation
ich behaupte weil das so schön
provokativ ist dass in dieser hinsicht
die inflation des ethik begriffs es geht
mir nicht und im griff immer mit dem
anspruch ich habe die lösung es gibt
eine lösung funktions äquivalent ist mit
dem neuen fundamentalismus also tram
personal ofd der mit der rechten immer
verbunden
die sind völlig anders und ich will auch
nicht verschweigen dass also wenn ich
wählen müsste mir trotz allem die
politisch korrekten lieber wären aber
sind beides reduktion von komplexität
ist haben den begriff erklärt angesicht
eine komplexität des alltags die als
überlasst erlebt er will jetzt gleich
nachfragen weil ich bin selbst als
beobachter des kulturellen erbes in
einer verwirrung ich kenne mich nicht
mehr aus früher war es so dass die
konservativen mit moral argumentiert
haben heute scheint es die politisch
fortschrittlichen die sogenannte
progressive sind die moral vertreter das
fast eine verkehrung der situation die
linke die früher normen moralischer art
niederreißen wollte setzt sie wieder ein
und die rechte sagt wir wollen diese
normen nicht das ist doch immer ganz
paradoxe verwirrende situation ja das
stimmt aber es ist halt schon es hat
auch schon eine gewisse logik und ich
denke auch tatsächlich dass es mit mit
ohnmacht zu tun hat auch diese idee von
fortschritt ist automatisch gut ist
etwas positiver sehr und auch dieser
idee der linken und ich würde mich
durchaus er es als angehörige vom linken
lager hier auch verstehen wollen ja aber
trotzdem dies aber dieser anspruch auf
bildung als dieses mittel zur
vervollkommnung des menschen zu sehen ja
also all diese fortschritte sozusagen
dieses positive fortschrittsdenken hat
sich ja so nicht erfüllt wir haben
fortschritte gemacht aber wir können
sehen wir uns auch um emanzipation geht
wenn es auch um wahl bewegungen geht
auch jetzt teams wichtig wieder recht
rechtspopulismus rechter parteien dass
sie da auch ordentliche rückschritte
erleben also so einfach ist die sache
nicht also weder soziale gerechtigkeit
durch bildung durchzusetzen als auch
gesellschaftlichen fortschritt durch
bestimmte moralische vorschriften
einzuleiten also so einfach ist die
sache nicht
und mir gefällt da ganz gut schon auch
ein gewisser linster minister ansatz her
da muss ich immer an das buch von peter
singer denken dass mir da recht gut
gefallen hat ein australischer philosoph
ganz genau
also im hinblick auf was genau aber
wahrscheinlich auch aus gutem grund der
schon auch sagt dass die linke hinnehmen
müsste dass es mit dieser optimierung
der menschlichen natur ja nicht so weit
her ist und dass wir die die grenzen
schon anerkennen müssten also unsere
tendenz zur hierarchien unsere bands
auch zu gewalt unsere den dance auch
freiheiten dann soweit zu missbrauchen
wie wir sie jetzt brauchen können und
auch darauf zu vergessen dass er mit
diesem freiheit nach pflichten kommen
also sie jetzt verbindlichkeit und zu
welchen gruppen ich mich noch zugehörig
fühlen und das gefällt mir eigentlich
ganz gut weil es nicht nur den
freiheitsbegriff auf ein erlebbares maß
und ein
trotzdem recht kompliziertes maß
zurückschraubt sondern auch
weil ich finde dass der individualismus
schon sehr sehr überzogen reagiert auf
das was man selber für sich will also
wenn man selbst den moralischen
zeigefinger erhebt und wie viel man
tatsächlich auch von eigenen privilegien
freiheiten zurückstecken würde und zum
beispiel auch eine moral zu entsprechen
ja das ist ihr flug schaden das bringt
uns auf einen vorschlag der deutschen
philosophen ihrer kollegin thea dorn die
gesagt hat wir brauchen eine
moralisierung pause weil sie glaubt dass
diese ständige sensibilisierung der
gesellschaft derzeit etwas auslöst was
wir vielleicht auch alle leben nämlich
den backlash er nutzt den rechten den
rechten populisten die sich dagegen und
sie sagt es ja sind dynamiken die
einander hängen profilieren weil sie zum
beispiel sagen wir sind frei wir trauen
uns das noch diese regeln geld nicht für
uns wir sind die eigentlich freien
menschen und dabei doch eine eigene
dominanz strategie verfolgen darf ich
mal 1 als auch aufgreifen was jetzt in
den letzten fünf minuten für geschwebt
ist also auch als provokation aber ich
frag mich ganz im ernst ob diese
topologie diese dieses diese
kartographie sozusagen von rechts und
links heute noch funktionieren
und ich werde es also am beispiel meines
präsidenten den ich nicht gewählt habe
american citizen ist dass mein präsident
industrien wir nennen den namen donald
trump damit er ja eigentlich natürlich
optional ist ein anderer fall aber ein
kollege den intellektuell sehr schätze
der konnte das konnte ihn nicht daran
hindern heute in der regierung und im
außenministerium ist breit er glaubt ram
zu bedeuten hat man gesagt und diese
beschreibung ist nicht schlecht trump
ist eigentlich eine mischung eine ganz
eigenartige mischung von klassischen
linken und rechten elementen
man muss sehen was es in den usa noch an
an klassischen proletariat gibt
rasberger also dort arbeitslose in
pennsylvania zum beispiel in detroit
also immer die große industrie wenn zu
80% trump ja also als unsere studenten
in stanford nach der wahl von kramp von
rechts und links über den campus liefen
da spanisch sagte schäuble
doch haben jetzt ihre wenn das volk
geeint ist kann es nie
werden das war eine furchtbare ironie
weil in dem klassischen sinn das volk
eigentlich trump gewählte nicht nicht
sie wird kann wenn überhaupt nicht
silicon valley band welt demokratische
dass zum beispiel dieses element auf der
anderen seite gibt es ein talent was
trump sicher hat es dieses resonanz
talent also auf diesen der brauch
eigentlich gar nichts zu sagen es gibt
eine stimmlage tatsächlich eine
stimmlage
es gibt eine gestik auf die viele leute
das wäre diese dieses charisma dieses
negative charisma wenn eine sache der
rechten und wenn ich mich jetzt frage
was ist ramms ideologische position
die gibt es nicht die ist völlig
inkohärent von tag zu tag
das kommt gerade darauf an was die erste
idee ist wenn wir den ersten twitter
schickt und wenn ich das sagen darf in
einem öffentlich-rechtlichen medium
schickt den ersten twitter wenn er sehr
früh morgens auf die toilette geht also
der erste täter ist normale washington
times kostheim wo der zweite um 4 uhr
und die sind schon die die zwei ersten
das im in korinth also zu sagen trump
ist rechts ist insofern gefährlich weil
man damit sozusagen das phänomen das man
analysieren muss unterschätzt also nicht
unterschätzt dass sie ein großer
politiker wäre dass das phänomen ist
schwieriger als recht wie jetzt muss ich
mal widersprechen weil es ist doch klar
dass du in dieser ansprache trump ein
energie raum anzapft der sehr viel mit
den privilegien von männern gegenüber
frauen zu tun hat diese raesfeld diese
arbeiter haben viele privilegien im
status verloren und jetzt haben sie
angst dass sie noch ihre gender wolle
ihre männlichkeit rolle verlieren und
schwamm benutzt das und natürlich auch
die progressive linke rhetorik der innen
des gender sprech um das zu mobilisieren
oli dass ich sagen jawohl ich dann auch
mal dazu sagen würde sie haben sie
längst verloren ja also ich meine das
ist ja auch jetzt keine plötzliche
entwicklung sondern auch die entwertung
von von körperkraft er hat ja schon sehr
früh eingesetzt also die zunehmende
digitalisierung mobilisierung die zeigte
nur an was längst im laufen ist und
was nochmal männlichkeit ganz extrem
hinterfragen wer da kommt einiges auf
uns zu glaube ich auch gesellschaftliche
der krise dass man das mal sehen ich
glaube tatsächlich dass es nicht eine
krise des mannes sondern er mir dieses
einen vielleicht männlichkeit spieles
auch ist also dieser supermann ist das
auch trump da verkörpert und ich würde
auch nicht sagen dass man ihn eindeutig
jetzt als rechten politiker also ich
glaube es ist wirklich schwierig
politiker in rechts und links
einzuteilen
ich glaube nicht dass es unbedingt auf
die wähler zutrifft denn ich denke dass
es eine rechte wählerschaft gibt die
durch seine position gestärkt wird die
seine positionen zur männlichkeit zu
überlegenheit der weißen attraktiv
findet die unterstützenswert findet da
muss man gar nicht recht sein
unterstützt jedenfalls die ich glaube
allerdings dass die linken positionen
sehr stark im schwächeln sind nämlich
auch konfrontiert mit der realität eben
dass ich sachen nicht so einfach innen
lassen und dass sich wirklichkeit eben
nicht einfach nur durch sprach
politische maßnahmen verändern lassen
also sprachpolitik ja das ist wichtig
aber nur wenn politische maßnahmen
folgen um das was ich schon sehr
auffällig viele wie gesagt jetzt aus
meiner beobachtung auch mit den sozialen
medien dass es wahnsinnig kostengünstig
ist nur einen einen politisch korrekten
suite abzusetzen
aber diese änderungen tatsächlich
ökonomisch durchzusetzen ja oder
gesellschaftlich durchzusetzen
das wird mit einem zieht nicht erledigt
sein schreibt mir ein ganz wichtiger
punkt weil in der kritik dieser
moralisierung strategie wird gesagt das
macht die linke deswegen weil sie den
großen ökonomischen kampf um das system
verloren hat und hier im kleinen
symbolpolitische gewinne verzeichnen
kann
das ist an sich eine form der
verzweiflung wir können die große
kapitalismus frage nicht mehr stellen
aber wir haben diese kleinen kämpfe die
wir moralisieren und so gewinnen wir im
öffentlichen raum relevanz es gibt ja
ich weiss nicht global dabei sind jetzt
gerade mit mit morales in bolivien zum
beispiel das war der letzte sein
klassische linke der also für viele
andere südamerikanische länder nach dem
jura also lula ist seit zwei tagen an
den fünf tagen nicht mehr im gefängnis
ehemalige brasilianische präsident aber
das war die letzte hoffnung
ich denke es gibt im moment eine
situation wenn man etwa auf die deutsche
demographie der wähler sieht dass das
was ich so halb polemisch den eu
sozialdemokratismus genannt habe ich
meine sozialdemokratismus weil man dann
nicht unbedingt einer
sozialdemokratischen partei sein muss es
gab einen konsens der mitte
das war ein konsens über den
wohlfahrtsstaat das war ein konsens dass
steuern nicht zu niedrig sein sollen und
so weiter und so weiter und
eigenartigerweise behalten
diese politiker und diese parteien ihren
eigentlich alleinvertretungsanspruch bei
sind aber demografisch geschrumpft also
für mich ist eine frage im blick auf die
deutsche situation ich weiß nicht ob in
der schweiz das wort auch verwendet wird
man war ist das in den deutschen
bundesländern die früher die deutsche
demokratische republik waren diese afd
vor allem jetzt in thüringen großen
erfolg wird
30 prozent mehr also unendlich mehr
sozialdemokratische partei unendlich
mehr als die linke
und was bedeutet eigentlich dieses sich
abgehängt fühlen was ist das für ein
gefühl und kann man das als rechts
qualifizieren also erstens ist mir nicht
ganz klar was das sich abgehängt finden
bedeutet also welche dynamik da einsetzt
obwohl man das auch für andere nationen
einsetzen kann deshalb sicher in
brasilien auch eine rolle gespielt
also was und wie ein flächenmäßig viel
größeres land ist und wenn man es denn
identifizieren könnte könnte man das
tatsächlich der einen oder der anderen
seite zu rechnen
ich wollte noch was sagen zu
kapitalismus frage ich geb rechts sie
wird nicht gestellt sie sollte gestellt
werden ich glaube das ist einer der
wesentlichen gründe warum auch die die
als abgehängt sich vielleicht selber
auch klassifizieren würden oder sich
selber so einschätzen da mehr zuspruch
von den rechten kriegen weiß tatsächlich
da für sie etwas gibt wenn auch nur
trost
naja oder verständnis für zorn und ärger
und ich glaube da hat die linke auch in
österreich nachholbedarf
aber ich glaube dass einer der großen
oder eine große problematik ist dass man
sich auch nicht mehr traut diese frage
anzusprechen dass die zu groß scheint
nicht erscheint also ich kann mich
allerdings trage auch also auch wie kann
man sozialdemokratie anders denken wir
haben diese krise auch in österreich ja
wie kann man das umlenken was wer ist
jetzt eigentlich die klientel
ich war zum beispiel sehr erstaunlich
dass die sozialdemokratie in österreich
beispielsweise sich nicht mit dem regler
selbstständigen beschäftigt hat also wir
haben eine große anzahl an jungen
menschen die selbstständig ist wie
versucht durchzukommen
die wurde nicht gestellt also man
versucht dann eher den zionisten wenn
zunächst in anzusprechen ja aber die
jungen die wirklich in prekären
verhältnissen sind sie jetzt nicht mehr
unbedingt arbeiter arbeiterinnen sondern
eben die aus der uni kommen
selbstständig ihren weg machen müssen ja
wahnsinnig interessant wie man von der
moralisierung der sprache zur krise der
sozialdemokratie kommt sie haben diesen
übergang gut entwickelt das wort
abgehängt zu mir aber als stichwort für
einen übergang dienen es gibt nämlich
die moralisierung frage vor allem in der
kunst wir sprachen das an und ein
beispiel an dem man das sehr gut zeigen
kann sind die werke des malers balthus
der abgehängt werden soll oder nicht
wir trinken mal was eines wir sehen das
sofort als problematisch und die sagen
gleich was problematisch ist es nicht
die katze immer wieder wenn dieser werke
gezeigt werden gibt es größere
petitionen online petitionen von frauen
die sagen zeigt diese werke nicht
freiherrn würden sie so eine petition
unterzeichnen nein das würde ich nicht
tun dann also das kann ich ganz
eindeutig sagen dass ich das nicht so
müde und zwar nicht
unbedingt mit dem argument um die
freiheit der kunst zu schützen sondern
tatsächlich weil ich sehr viel
aussagekräftiger habe was wir in dem
bild sehen was uns daran stört und
diesen aspekt eben gerade an
kunstschätze dass es einen stachel gibt
der dazu bringt nachzudenken was
passiert was wird hier gezeigt was
können wir zur diskussion stellen warum
diese das diskussions anlass wurden als
diskussions anlass und aber auch
vielleicht erst als zeitdokument für
eine epoche für eine art das modell
auszuwählen
also jetzt zu sagen wir zensieren kunst
vor allem jetzt im hinblick auf kunst
vergangener künstler die schon tot sind
finde ich äußerst problematisch also
dann wird auch nicht mehr viel über
bleiben denn was wir das nächste sein
also kann man dann über unity als über
nacktheit sprechen auf bildern
ich glaube dann werden unsere museen
sehr schnell leer sein
der bericht wie kann ich mir das
vorstellen sie haben 30 jahren standort
unterrichtet wenn sie jetzt in einem
kurs dieses bild zeigen sagen sie da
vorher zu den studenten und studentinnen
achtung jetzt kommt ein bild das sie
stören würde wie gehen sie damit um
klassenraum um also meine persönliche
antwort heißt und ihr habt mich
zumindest nie in konflikt gebracht
das natürlich das interessiert nicht an
unsere zuschauer wenn man am
unterrichten beruf ist dass ich in
verschiedenen seminaren oder vorlesungen
oder oder über kleinen gruppen andere
dynamiken entwickelt und wenn man nicht
alles nur theoretisiert entwickelt man
dafür ein gefühl
also ich kann jetzt nicht sagen generell
würde ich nie eine dieser warnungen
aussprechen dieser trick allerdings das
könnte so sein
in einer anderen klasse brauche ich das
nicht unbedingt weil man vielleicht
schon vorher war ein student vorher
etwas gesagt hat was die universität
angeht denke ich eigentlich also nicht
nur im blick auf kunst die universität
sollte der raum sein
ich selbst wenn das ganz gerne riskantes
denken wo keine position durch ein tabu
von vornherein ausgeschlossen ist
es muss ist oder ich muss vielleicht
nicht aber ich denke sollte in jeder
gesellschaft einen raum geben und er
sollte auch sowie universitäten man sagt
elfenbeintürmen das finde ich positiv
isoliert seien vom gesellschaftlichen
alter aber es muss einen raum geben
können wo man auch die tatsächlich
unangenehmen fragen stellen oder
tatsächlich über unangenehme wahrheit
rede die vielleicht sozusagen nicht
sozialverträglich sind nicht und aus
diesem grund denke ich ich kann mir
durchaus kontexte vorstellen
auch regionale kontexte wo ich dieses
bild vielleicht nicht hängen würde
und diese ausrede ja man muss die leute
provozieren also wie man französischen
für epa tilo busch war ich meine das ist
auch irgendwie ein ausgelutscht der
kaugummi man muss nicht die leute immer
quellen mit irgendwas aber es muss räume
geben wo dieses bild ausgestellt werden
kann
aber das bild der räume das betrifft
eine weiteres großes schlagwort nämlich
der safe spaces sie argumentieren dafür
dass die universitäten räume sind in
denen das risiko auch der verletzung
vielleicht das schmerzes erfahren werden
kann und eine andere gruppe sagt gerade
universitäten sollten räume der
sicherheit sein in denen man von diesen
aggressionen von diesen bildern
verschont bleibt weil sie mich für etwas
stehen für das freie denken gerade nicht
steht
ich muss noch eine sekunde zurück kommen
zu dem bild sind konservativ naja ich
finde auch das ist wieder ein gutes
beispiel für für doppelmoral ja also
wenn ich mir anschaue welche bilder von
gewalt zum beispiel in zeitungen in den
medien transportiert werden dürfen ja
die sind eingeschränkt da gibt es dann
vorschriften was gezeigt werden darf so
dann schalte ich wo auch immer fernsehen
netflix 1
da ist gewalt ohne ende im schlimmsten
ausmaßes so detailliert mit so viel blut
und so exakt ich denke da zum beispiel
an das sehr populäre game of thrones wo
ich mir denke gut also ich habe auf der
einen seite diese träger warnungen auf
der anderen seite wird gewalt sexualität
auf diese art und weise gezeigt ja es
wird diskutiert wie oft darf dieses bild
hängen muss das abgehängt werden
nebenbei existiert
sendungen wie game of thrones die ganz
unproblematisch konsumiert werden die
einschaltquoten haben die alles andere
überträgt ein ganz anderes frauenbild
transport ein ganz anderes frauenbild
ganz anderes bild von sexualität von
gewalt von männlichkeit was auch immer
transportiert und wie gesagt also das
halte ich für sehr problematisch dass
wir sagen guttbye bildern fangen wir an
zu diskutieren
wir fangen an zu diskutierenden dürfen
wir einen goethe noch so lesen dürfen
wir keine bücher noch so lesen aber wir
haben auf der einen seite derartige
massenmediale finn lehne aber könnte
argumentieren
gerade solche großen ausstellungen
kreise kulturinstitutionen haben eine
normative wirkung sie setzen ein trend
der dann durch sichert die frage ist was
bedeutet wir und was bedeutet normativ
also wenn ich mir eine gesellschaft nach
seinem wahrscheinlichen tod vorstelle
meine frau sympathischerweise zum
30-jährigen hochzeitstag gesagt sie
möchte noch mal 30 jahre also also 100
wäre ich vielleicht aber was könnte eine
gesellschaft sein die besser
funktionierte weniger spannung
funktioniert wo diese berühmten spaltung
die er nicht mehr nur ein amerikanisches
phänomen sind ja die sehr tief durch die
meisten westlichen gesellschaften gehen
wie sein die zu vermeiden und ich frage
mich manchmal ob es auch nicht ein
schwanz sozusagen dieses moralisierend
ist dass man beständig im sinn
allgemeiner verbindlichkeiten
argumentiert ich habe vorhin gesagt also
dass es zum gesetz erhoben wird ja
betonen das sieht ja nicht also es gibt
also ich werde dagegen das game of
thrones ich habe überhaupt noch nie eine
folge gesehen aber auch weil das leben
ist kurz ist und man nicht für alles
zeit hatte ich für absolut dagegen daß
das nicht gesendet werden
ich war absolut dagegen daß das boxen
verboten wird
um das von der sport ästhetik zu sagen
aber es bedeutet natürlich nicht dass
jeder boxen muss das jeder
zu boxkämpfen geben muss oder jede game
of thrones 1 also ich meine ich kann für
mich entscheiden
ich kann bis zu einem gewissen grad
als erzieher in meiner familie so lange
meine familie meine kinder nicht
volljährig sind bestimmte punkte
verbindlich machen aber das bedeutet
nicht mal dass das was in meiner familie
verbindlich ist also war es neben meiner
familie aber zum beispiel der
sonntäglichen kirchenbesuch in der
nächsten familie verbindlich sein muss
aber muss man nicht sagen
diese eltern dürfen aber ihre kinder
nicht verpflichtet in die kirche zu
gehen oder diese eltern dürfen ihren
kinder nicht verbieten game of thrones
zu sehen also man muss nicht immer so
argumentieren als sei die menschheit mit
jeder entscheidung schon immer
prädestiniert jetzt gibt es aber einen
diskurs fällt ein neues das für die
moralisierung und für den einsatz der
moral besonders wichtig ist und da geht
es um die gesamte menschheit und vor
allem um diese die ökologische frage es
ist ja sehr leicht sichtbar wenn sie von
den nächsten 30 jahren sprechen dass
jede handlung die wir tun auf ihren
nachhaltigkeitsaspekt auf ihre
ökologische valencia prüft wird da tut
sich doch ein tor auf in dem die moral
total wird in dem sinne dass alles was
wir tun lokalisierbar wird ja und man
muss ständig ein schlechtes gewissen
haben ja ja und das kann ich gut
nachvollziehen ich finde dass das weckt
auch sehr gut bei mir aber ich glaube
auch wieder ein super phänomen auch in
bezug auf flugschauen oder auf ein
käufer ja also dieses ökologisch gut
sein muss man sich ja auch leisten
können und das finde ich eigentlich
besonders bösartig ja also zu sagen ich
kann es mir leisten dort einkaufen zu
gehen ich kann es mir leisten diese
produkte auszuwählen ich kann mir
leisten mit dieser sendung anzuschauen
ich kann mir leisten in dieser autoren
die sat 1 und rissen
ich habe über bläst ins museum zu gehen
ja also damit ist das problem stellt
sich für mich und für andere stellt sich
das problem
das habe er liebte diskussion wie ich da
höre
zum beispiel ich kenne die diskussion
auch wo dann versuchte den familien
dafür zu argumentieren nicht mehr zu
fliegen und ja ich halte auch fliegen
für ein ökologisches problem so wie wir
es ausführen aber jetzt jemanden der
eine oder zwei wochen urlaub im jahr hat
sonst durch arbeitet das pflegen
verbieten zu wollen wenn es wir diese
person keine anderen alternativen gibt
auch finanziellen nicht bin ich gehe am
problem vorbei also wir haben schon auf
der einen seite diesen guten willen auch
ökologische maßnahmen zu ergreifen und
das wenig notwendig auch für den
einzelnen auf den auf der anderen seite
fehlt mir das engagement jetzt kommt es
durch die jugend das finde ich gut
von der politik zu fordern wieso kann
ich mir überhaupt warum steht mir als
konsument die wahl zwischen einem
ethisch korrekten und einen ethisch
inkorrekten produkt zu wählen
warum gibt es dieses ethisch inkorrekte
produkt überhaupt zur auswahl
also wenn wir tatsächlich aber dafür
fordern sie jetzt dass der staat im
prinzip wahlfreiheit vorwegnimmt für uns
und gewisse war frau nicht mehr zulässt
nein aber ich sage nur wir sind da auch
in einer doppelmoral drinnen zu sagen
der konsument geht jetzt rein und machte
diese moralisch gute das heißt
ökologisch ist das neue moralisch diese
ökologische entscheidung dafür der
andere kann sich nicht leisten der
andere ist moralisch schlecht und der
ist mir alles gut mit dem guten gewissen
heim aber als große maßnahme die
wirklich etwas ändert jetzt ist nämlich
dann noch ein also nicht ein größeres
stärkeres argument reinwerfen aber
sozusagen der fluchtpunkt der
ökologischen moral verschreibungen ist
er immer eine verewigung der menschheit
auf diesem planeten
ja also dass das scheint mir einmal
naturwissenschaftlich gesehen
evolutionstheorie tisch gesehen
in einer derart groteske weise
unwahrscheinlich dass man sich fragen
muss ja was wäre denn das ziel also soll
die menschheit noch 250.000 jahre weiter
existieren man sich ja fragen muss also
wie lange kann sie überhaupt weiter
existieren aufgrund der ressourcen also
weiter und so hat also
ich finde immer dass die voraussetzung
diese zahlreichen moral zumutungen also
wenn wir save the planet ja der greta
diskurs die voraussetzungen sind
ungeklärt bzw die voraussetzungen waren
faktisch die der griether diskurs ist
der diskurs ihrer vier kinder das geht
um die nächsten generationen
es geht um unsere kinder und unsere
enkel also ich meine meine enkel in der
schule zu höchsten leistungen was
trennschärfe angeht ausgebildet aber ich
kann nicht behaupten dass meine ängste
das ist also das zentrale der zentrale
punkt meiner enkel ist man könnte ja
vielleicht sagen dass dieses hochrechnen
also wir haben die erde nur von unseren
kindern geborgt das ist intellektuellen
diskurs obwohl ich sagen muss wie ihr
sehen sie schon sehr stark von einem
prozent rischen punkt aus ja also zu
sagen gut wir können also machen wir es
scheint mir dann auch verantwortungslos
zu sein also ja natürlich ist die frage
wie sich jetzt auch wirtschaft
entwickeln wird einer die ziemlich
sicher verzichtet oder zumindest für die
gesellschaften die am meisten profitiert
haben von allen wirtschaftlichen
entwicklungen bisher ja und jetzt kommen
wir wieder zur doppelmoral ich komme da
scheint noch immer nicht weg aber sage
jetzt mal scheinmoral dazu ja wenn man
dieses kurs geführt wird
jetzt gibt es ein billigauto ja das
fahren leistbar macht ob jetzt in indien
oder in china
naja wie sollen sie jetzt aber nicht so
anstellen sollen sich jetzt bitte keine
auto kaufen wenn jetzt eine milliarde
menschen auf die welt kommt die sich
dort kommt echtes fragen jetzt die
gerechtigkeitsfragen sind ganz genau was
man erwartet dann plötzlich von den
anderen vernünftiger zu sein sie selbst
besser einzuschränken als man selbst
bereit ist ja und das kann sich
tatsächlich nicht ausgehen also ich
verstehe auch dass wir da auf konflikte
zu steuern müssen weil wie gesagt das
moralische gewissen zu verkörpern wie
wir es ja auch gerne in europa tun und
dann von anderen zu fordern was ich
selber nicht und ich habe nicht so viel
zu tun auf der welt aber moral doch also
europa als moralische supermacht so
scharf formulieren aber ich denke
tatsächlich dass sogar diese dieser
diskurs von moral umgelegt auf einen
größeren die frage zu stellen was gutes
leben bedeutet das wäre mal eine schöne
diskurs in europa starten können bei den
als kurz vorm ende sind und weil sie
beides autoren und autorinnen sind die
über das gute leben über eine kunst des
lebens nachdenken kurz und pointiert
gesagt welche rolle spielt für sie die
frage nach der moral in ihrem existenz
ideal eines guten lebens
[Musik]
ich glaube es ist mir die untersuchung
was tatsächlich gutes leben ausmacht und
zwar ich will das nicht mechanisch
übertreiben aber jenseits von diesem gut
und böse ich glaube dass wir uns
automatisch einordnen ich glaube dass
wir tendenzen haben uns in die ein oder
andere richtung entwickeln zu wollen
unseren eigenen neigungen zu folgen
die idee geboren sind mit welchem
geschlecht wie auch immer mit welchem
privilegien
ich glaube dass das gute leben ist eine
möglichkeit sich mit dem anderen
kritisch auseinanderzusetzen um zu
reiben
der andere als der andere als
reibungslos
bei ihnen in der ästhetik der existenz
dieser letzten es experten das ist ein
bisschen anderer fokus
ja also zunächst mal wird wenn man in
den geisteswissenschaften sein leben als
hochschullehrer verbringt immer erwartet
dass man eine besondere kompetenz für
ethische fragen hätte ja und ich muss
sagen also ich fühle mich mit den
kleinen in anführungszeichen ethischen
fragen meines lebens meine familie
[Musik]
tendenziell so gefordert und oft
überfordert dass ich eigentlich ganz
froh bin um einen altmodischen begriff
zu gebrauchen wenn ich einigermaßen
anständig durchs leben kommen also
anständig in dem sinn der dawn in frick
payback karten und human aber gesagt der
ball ist gentleman das nun also der kein
der decken keine leiden auffällig
aber die vorstellung dass ich eine
besondere kompetenz haben könnte zu
sehen was das gute leben für andere sein
könnte oder sollte und der angab
verschreibung machen sollte weil ich
sage ja wir haben doch die er dürfe in
seinen kindern geborgt kommt mir sehr
absurd vor also die dimension ethik in
meinem leben dieses anständig sagen ja
also anständig sein gar nicht im sinn
einer norm sondern anständig sein im
sinn von mit leuten auskommen anständig
sein im sinn von meinem tankfahrzeugen
dass ich schätze dass er da ist
beziehungsweise haben jetzt an tesla
gekauft aber also früher dem
tankfahrzeug dass ich schätze dass er da
ist also auch in einem sozialen sinn und
zwar nicht in diesem in diesem
herablassenden sinologen jetzt den
produkten schätzen das ist wir teilen
diesen planeten und das ist eine frau
die anständig ist und was muss ich
respekt ihn anständig durchs leben
kommen nicht totalisierten aber auch
nicht gleichgültig gegenüber dem anderen
das sind handreichungen die wir in
dieser sehr schwierigen frage und dieser
diskussion mitnehmen frau herum recht
herzlichen dank dass die larven und
nächste woche sehen wir uns wieder dann
rede ich in der sternstunde philosophie
mit der kamerunerin weil ihr tata und
dem kulturwissenschaftler giga über afro
topia über afrikas zukunft und europas
vergangenheit
hier geht es gleich weiter mit der
sternstunde kunst mit einem film zu
kunst auf den kleinen inseln im
kreisverkehr
bleiben sie also dran und denken sie
weiter
[Musik]